[Musique]
un véhicule qui ne sert plus en Corée en
Le Japon aux États-Unis ce qu'ils sont
à vendre d'occasion
ils apportent et entrent par la zone
Franca de Iquique pour qu'en elle dans un
pourcentage important peut le vendre
pour les autres pays dont le Chili
aussi particulièrement ici dans le nord
et aussi pour le vendre à la Bolivie
Argentine Paraguay etc. pas alors
il y a aussi un commerce
[Musique]
nous avons abandonné nous sentons que notre
terre a été transformée en une zone de
sacrifice enfin car j'insiste sur le fait qu'ils sont
les inoculeux du monde qui viennent
votez vos ordures ici, c'est comme le patio
derrière on n'est même plus le patio
cul local mais nous faisons partie
l'arrière du monde c'est pire s'il n'y a pas
conscience de pouvoir encore résoudre
ce problème au contraire
[Musique]
non et ici tu n'as pas à vivre avec
que pour la pollution
[Musique]